all right everyone Pontius Sandoval 8 so
welcome to the final lecture of sis 229
this quarter or I guess to the home
viewers welcome to the season finale so
what like to do today is wrap up our
discussion on reinforcer learning and
then and it will conclude the class so I
think you know over the last few
lectures you saw a lot of we saw a lot
at nav so maybe as a brief interlude
here are some videos so sample
autonomous helicopter you know there's a
project that I know Peter view Adam
coats some some former students here now
some of the machine learning greats were
on when they were PhD students here and
oh and and and I think using algorithms
similar to the ones you learned in this
class how do you make a helicopter fly
so it just have fun there's a video shot
on top of one of the Stanford soccer
fields I was actually a cameraman that
day and zooming out the camera see the
trees planted in the sky
say it turns out there's a small radio
control helicopter it turns out that
when you're very far away you can't tell
if this is a small radio control
helicopter if there is like a helicopter
with people sitting there named so there
was actually this um you know Foods is
on a kind of soccer field the big grass
field off Santo Road it turns out across
Sand Hill Road and what that high-rises
there was a those an elder lady that
lives in one of those apartments and
when if she saw this she would call 911
and say hey this copter about the crash
and then the the firemen would come out
and I and I think they were Polly relief
probably disappointed that there was no
one for us for them to save I think um
and so and and I think um let's see one
of the things I promise to do in the
debugging learning algorithms lecture
was to just go over the reinforcement
learning example again so let me just do
that now but with notation that I think
you now understand compared to oh yes
oh you as an aerobatic stunt yeah that I
I don't think there's a good reason for
fine how it drops upside down other than
that you can there are a lot of videos
of samples on the side cough to find all
sorts of stunts go to heli stanford.edu
Akio I don't stanford.edu and the stem
photons are cogs did a lot more than
fine upside down I mean make some
maneuvers that look aerodynamically
impossible such as a helicopter that
looks like a stumbling just spinning
randomly but staying the same place in
the air right now it's called the chaos
maneuver and if you look how to go wow
this work was turning upside down
spinning around the area same direction
but it's just staying right there in the
air and not crashing and so the
maneuvers like that that um the very
best human pilots in the world can fly
with helicopters and I think this was
just
demonstration yes and I think a lot of
this work wound up influencing something
later work on the quadcopter drones and
a few research labs and yeah I think it
was a difficult control problem and it
was it was one of those things you do
when you're you when you're a university
you want to solve on the hardest
problems round um but one that step
through of you the debugging process
that we went through as we were you're
building a helicopter like this so when
you're trying to get a helicopter to fly
upside down fly stunts you don't wanna
crash too often so step one is build a
model or build a simulator of the
helicopter right much much as you saw we
start to talk about fitted value
iteration and then choose the reward
function like that and it turns out that
specifies the reward function for
staying a place is not that hard you
know like a quadratic function like that
works okay but if you want a helicopter
to fly aggressive maneuvers it's
actually quite tricky to specify what is
a good turn for a helicopter and then
what you do is you run the course to
learning algorithm to try to maximize
say the final horizon MTP formulation
maximize some rewards over T time steps
you get a policy pie and then whenever
you do this the first time you do this
you find that the resulting controller
does much worse than the human pilot and
the question is whether you do Nix right
this is better this is almost I think
this is almost exactly the slide I
showed you last time because I might
clean up the slide using reinforcement
or any notation rather than it slightly
simplified notation you saw before you
learned about reinforcement or anything
and so the question is and and again if
you work on the reinforcer learning
problem yourself you know there's a good
chance you have to answer this question
yourself for whatever
robot or other reinforcement learning or
factory automation or stock trading
system or whatever it is you are trying
to get to work with enforcement learning
but do you want to improve the modelsim
model or doing a modified reward
function or do you want to modify the
reinforcement learning algorithm
okay and multiply the reports of
learning album includes things like
playing with the descritization that
you're using if you are taking a
continuously MDP and discretizing it's a
solve of a finite state MVP formulation
or modifying the reinforcement learning
algorithm and Cruz also may be choosing
new features to use in physicality
iteration small things we could try or
maybe instead of using a linear function
approximator
instead of fitting a linear function for
fit evaluation maybe you want to use a
bigger you know deep neural network
right but so which of these steps is the
most useful thing to do so this is the
analysis of those three things you know
if I give you a second meters right but
if these three statements are true then
the learn controller should have flown
well on the helicopter right and so
those three sentences correspond to the
three things in yellow that you could
work on is a problem that you know
statement one is false that the
assimilator isn't good enough for his
problem that statement two is false that
oh sorry I think actually two and three
are reverse right but the three
statements correspond to three things in
yellow I think two and three are and are
in opposite order right is the arrow
alpha maximizing some rewards is a
reward function actually the right thing
to maximize and so here the Diagnostics
you could use to see this helicopter
simulator is accurate
well first check if the policy flies
well in simulation if your policy flies
one simulation but not in real life then
this shows that the problem is with your
simulator and you should try to learn a
better model for your helicopter right
and if you're using a linear model this
with the matrices a and B if you know st
plus 1 equals a st plus ba t if you try
try anymore
or maybe try a nonlinear model but if
you find it the problem is not your
simulator if you find that your policy
is flying poorly in simulation and
flying poorly in real life right then
this is the diagnostic I will use so I
shall show these two lines
so let's that human be the human control
policy so hire a human pilot which we
did we're fortunate that one of the best
what one of them America is tall you
know aerobatic helicopter pilots working
with us and he using his control signals
radio control can make a helicopter fly
upside down tumble do flips loops rows
so we had very good human pilot help us
fly the helicopter manually so what you
can do is test whether or not the so
this this thing here right that's just a
payoff of the learned policy as measured
on your reward function so check if the
learn policy achieves a better or a
worse payoff then a human pilot you can
write and so that means you know go
ahead and let the learn policy fly the
helicopter and we get the humans up fi
the helicopter and compute the summer
rewards on the sequence of states that
these two systems take the helicopter
through and just see whether the human
or the learn policy achieves a higher
payoff achieves a higher summer rewards
and if the payoff achieved by the
learning algorithm is less than a payoff
achieved by the human then this shows
that the learned policy is not actually
maximizing the summer rewards right
because whatever human is doing you know
he or she is doing a better job
maximizing some rewards then the learn
policy so this means that you should you
know consider working on the
reinforcement learning algorithm to try
to make it do a better job maximizing
the Sun removals and then on the flip
side it is an equality goes the other
way right so positive if the payoff or
the rol
is greater than the payoff of the human
then what that means is that the ORR
algorithm is actually doing a better job
maximizing the summer rewards but
they're still flying worse so what this
tells you is that doing a really good
job maximizing some rewards does not
correspond to how you actually want the
helicopter to fly and so that means that
maybe you should work on improving the
reward function that the reward function
is not capturing what's actually most
important to find helicopter well and
then you multiply the reward function
right so in a typical workflow I'm going
to describe to you what what what it
feels like to work on the machine
learning project like this and it was a
big multi or machine learning project
but when you're working on a big
complicated machine learning project
like this the bottleneck moves around
meaning that you build a helicopter get
a human pilot fly it you're getting the
world near on these Diagnostics and
maybe the first time you do this you
find wow the simulator is really
inaccurate then you are going to work on
improving the simulator for a couple
months and then you know and every now
and then you come back and rerun this
diagnostic then maybe for the first two
months the project you keep on saying
yep soon this is not good enough so it's
not good enough so as long enough after
working on this simulator for a couple
months you you may find that item one
that's no longer the problem you might
then find that item three is the problem
the simulator is now good enough but
when you run this diagnostic two months
in the project you might say wow looks
like you're our algorithm is maximally
reward function but this is not good
flying so now I think the biggest
problem for the project or the biggest
bottleneck with the project is that the
reward function is not good enough and
then you might spend you know another
one or two or three or sometimes longer
months working to try to improve the
reward function and you might do that
for a while and then when the reward
function is good enough then that
exposes the next problem your system
which might be that the ROI algorithm is
good enough and so the problem you
should be working on actually moves
around and it's different in different
phases of the project and when you're
working on this it feels like every time
you solve the current problem that
exposes the Nix
most important to work on then you work
on that and we solve that then this
helps you identify an explosive next
most important element work on and you
kind of keep doing that or you keep
iterating or keep solving problems until
hopefully you get a helicopter that does
what you wanted to but I think teams
that have the discipline to prioritize
according to Diagnostics like this tend
to be much more efficient teams that
kind of go by gut feeling in terms of
selecting you know what to what to spend
your time on all right any questions
about this oh sorry so again yeah I kind
of want to say yes let me think
yeah I wouldn't usually check step one
first and then if I think the simulator
is okay then look at steps two and three
maybe one of the thing about when you
work on these projects there is some
judgment involved so I think I'm
presenting these things as those a rigid
mathematical formula that's cut and dry
this formula says now working on step
one then this one says now work on step
three there is there is more judgment
involved because when you run these
things I'll say if you might say well
looks like the simulator is not that
good but it's kind of good and there's a
little bit ambiguous and oh looks like
you know and so that's what it often
feels like and so a team would get
together look for the evidence from all
three steps and then say you know well
maybe the simulator is not that good but
it's maybe good enough and but boy the
reinforcement the reward function is
really bad let's focus on that so there
is some surrounding a hard and fast rule
there there is some judgment needed to
make these decisions but having a so
when a reading machine there any teams
often my teams will you know run D
side.now sakes get together and look at
the evidence and then discuss in debate
what's the best way to move forward but
I think the process in making sure
you've that discussion to debate it's
much better than the alternative which
is you know someone just picked
something
very random and the team does that so
just yeah maybe I had the laptop up you
know a little bit of fun but a little
bit because I'm to illustrate fitted
value iteration let me just show another
reinforcement learning video oh and by
doing one of the I think if I look at
the future of a I featured machine
learning you know there's a lot of hype
about reinforcement learning for game
playing which is fine you know we all
like we all love computers playing
computer games like that's a great thing
I think but but I think that some of the
most exciting applications are
reinforced with learning coming down the
pipe I think will be robotics I don't
know the next few years even though
there are only a few success stories of
reinforcement they applied to robotics
there are more and more right now one of
the trends I see you know we look at the
academic publications and some of the
things making their way into industrial
environments is I think in the next
several years just based on the stuff I
see my friends in many different
companies and many different entities
are working on I think there will be a
rise of reinforcement learning
algorithms applied to robotics I think
there will be one important area to
watch out for right um but um so you
know there's a now Stanford video this
is again just using reinforcement
learning to get a robot dog to climb
over obstacles like these my friends
that were less generous did not want to
think of this as a robot dog they
thought it was more like a robot
cockroach
but I think cockroaches done that for
the x-ray coffee with six legs
yeah but so how do you program a robot
dog like this right to climb over
terrain so one of the key components is
work I am Zico Colter
now a Connie Mellon professor another
one of the machine learning greats is a
key part of this was a valley function
approximation where it dog sounds on the
left and it goes get to the right then
the approximate value function kind of
I'm simplifying a little bit right but
but the approximate value function tells
it given the 3d shape of the terrain the
middle plots is a height map where the
different shades tell you how tall is
the terrain but given the 3d shape the
terrain the dog learns a value function
that tells it what is the cost of
putting his feet on different locations
to the terrain and it learns among other
things you know not to put his feet at
the edge of a cliff because then it's
likely to slip off the edge of a cliff
and fall over right so but but hopefully
this gives a visualization of whether
learning value functions very very
complicated functions I'll say and okay
the states is very high dimension so
this is all kind of project on so 2d
space you can visualize it but but this
is what the simplified value function
looks like a robot like this okay all
right so with that let me return to the
so
um there's just one class of algorithms
I want to describe to you today which
are called policy search algorithms and
sometimes policy search is also called
direct policy search and to explain what
this means so far our approach to
reinforcement learning has been to first
learn or approximate the value function
you know approximate v-star and then use
that to learn or at least hopefully
approximate PI star right so we had you
saw a value iteration top reading Apollo
through a chinois philosophy to
reinforce the learning was to estimate
the value function and then use that you
know that equation with the arc max to
figure out what is pi star so this is an
indirect way of getting at a policy
because we would first try to figure out
was the value function in direct policy
search we try to find a good policy
directly right hence the term direct
policy search because you don't you go
straight for trying to find a good
policy without the intermediate step of
finding an approximation to the value
function so um let's see I'm gonna use
as the most Vida example the inverted
pendulum great so that is that thing
with the three things here and let's say
your actions are to accelerate left or
to a salary right right and then you
could have and you can have stay still a
cell it's from a cell rate that strong
salary right you could more than two
actions but let's just say you've an
inverted pendulum with two actions so if
you want to talk about pros and cons the
direct policy search later but if you
want to bypass direct policy search
you're going to apply policy search the
first step is to
come up with the class of policies you
are entertained or come up with the set
of functions you use to approximate the
policy so again to make an analogy when
you saw logistic regression for the
first time you know we kind of said that
we would approximate Y as a hypothesis
right whose form was governed by this
sigmoid function and you remember in
week 2 when I first described logistic
regression I kind of pulled this out of
a hat right and said oh yeah trust me
let's use logistic function and and then
later we saw there's a special case of
the generalized linear model but you
know we just had to write down some form
for how we will predict Y as a function
of X so in direct policy search we will
have to come up with a form for pi right
so right they just come up with a
function for however is an H indirect
policy search will have to come our way
for how we approximate the policy pi
right and so you know one thing we have
to do is say well maybe the action will
approximate with some policy PI may be
parametrized by theta and it's now a
function of the states and maybe it'll
be 1 over 1 plus e to the negative theta
transpose you know the state vector
right where the state vector may be
something like X dot and then the angle
at the angle dot right if if just this
fine maybe add an intercept
okay and I switch this from theta to Phi
to avoid conflict into notation okay um
this isn't really the form of the policy
were right so let me let me make one
more definition and then I'll show you a
form of a specific form of policy you
can use but it's actually not quite this
what we need to treat this a little bit
so the direct policy search algorithm
will use will use a stochastic policy so
this is a new definition so sarcastic
policy is a function so we're going to
use for the direct policy search
algorithm that you see today we're going
to use the classic policies meaning that
on every time step the policy will tell
you what's the chance you want to
accelerate left versus what's the chance
you want to settle right and then you
use a random number generator to select
either left or right to accelerate on
your inverted pendulum depending on the
policies there depending on the
probability is output by this policy
okay and so here's one example let's see
which is you can have
[Applause]
so you know continuing with the inverted
pendulum here's one policy that might be
reasonable where you say that let's see
so you know in a state that's the chancy
you take the salary right action is
given by this sigmoid function and the
chance that in the state that's you take
the accellerate left action is given by
that okay and here's one example for why
this might be a reasonable policy so
let's say the state vector s this one
X X dot Phi Phi dot where you know this
angle of the inverted pendulum is the
angle Phi and let's say for the sake of
arguments that we set the parameter of
this policy Phi to be um zero zero zero
one zero so in this case this is saying
that let's see so theta transpose s is
just equal to Phi right and so in this
case right because you know theta
transpose s just 1 times Phi everything
else gets multiplied zero and so in this
case the same that the chance to
accelerate to the right is equal to one
over one plus e to the negative how far
is the PO tilted over to the right and
so this policy gives you the effect that
the further the PO is tilted to the
right the more aggressively you want to
accelerate to the right okay so this is
very simple policy it's not a great
policy but it's not a totally
unreasonable policy which is well look
at how far the post tilted so that for
the right
apply sigmoid function and then
accelerate to the left or right you know
depending on how far is tilted to the
right now and and and because this is
the right so this is really the chance
of taking the ass a very right action as
a function of the PO angle pi right now
this is not the best policy because it
ignores all the features other than Phi
but if you were to set both theta equals
you know 0 negative 0.5 0 1 0 then this
policy the negative 0.5 now multiplies
into the exposition right now this new
policy if you have this value of theta
it takes an account how far is your
cards already to the right where I guess
this is the X distance and the further
your cart is already
I guess if your cart is on the set of
wheels right it's on the railway track
and you don't want to fall off the rim
and you want to keep the car kind of
Center you don't want to fall off the
end of your table but this now says the
further this is to the right already
your well the less likely you should be
to accelerate to the right okay and so
maybe this is suddenly better policy
there were descending parameters and
more generally what you would like is to
come up with five numbers that tells you
how to trade off how much you should
aside to the right based on the position
velocity angle and angular velocity of
their current state of the car of the of
the inverted pendulum and what a direct
policy search Alber will do is help you
come up with a set of numbers that
results in hopefully a reasonable policy
for controlling the inverted pendulum
hope and a policy that hopefully results
in a appropriate set of probabilities
that cause it to accelerate to the right
whenever's good to do so and Sarah to
let you know more often when it's good
to do so
so so I'll go is to find the five
parameters theta
so that's when we execute PI of s a we
maximize max of a theta the expected
value of R of s 0 is 0 plus dot dot plus
and so the reward function could be
negative 1 whenever the inverted
pendulum falls over and 0 whenever it
stays up or whatever or something that
measures how well you betcha Panem is
doing but the goal of a direct policy
search algorithm is to choose a set
parameters theta so that we actually the
policy you maximize your expected payoff
and I'm gonna use to find a horizon
setting for the album that was helpful
today okay and then one one other
difference between policy search
compared to estimating the value
function is that indirect policy search
here as 0 is a fixed initial State
it turns out that when we were
estimating the value function V saw you
found the best possible policy for
starting from any state right and
there's kind of no matter what state you
start from is simultaneously the best
possible policy for all states indirect
policy search we assume that either
there's a fixed start state fix initial
state at 0 or there's a fixed
distribution over initial States I'm
going to try to maximize the expected
reward or
back to your initial state or respect to
an initial priority distribution over
what is the initial state okay so that's
that's one other difference so
all right so this right is out the go is
a maximize overall theta the expected
value of R of s 0 a 0 because R of s 1 a
1 plus dot dot dot up to R of s t-80 you
know given pi theta and in order to
simplify the math we'll write on this
board today I'm just gonna set G equals
1 to simplify the math in order to not
carry such a long summation but it turns
out that so I'm just do like a 2 x mm DP
just to simplify the derivation but
everything works you know just with a
longer some if you have a more general
version of T and so this term here the
expectation is equal to sum over all
possible state action sequences right
and again this way go up to St and 80
but you just said capital T equals 1 um
what's the chance your MVP starts out
and some state as 0 so this is your
initial state distribution times the
chance that in that state you take the
first action a zero oh sorry just let me
write this out right so the chance of
your MVP going through the state action
sequence times
times that right so that's what it means
to self compute the expected value of
the payoff and so instead of writing all
this sum I'm just going to call this the
payoff and so this is equal to sum over
s 0 a 0 s 1 a 1 of the Chauncey MTP
starts in state 0 times the challenge
that in state 0 you end up choosing the
action a 0 times the chance governed by
the state transition probabilities that
you end up in state 1 state s 1 times
the chance a state that's one you end up
choosing so that's 1 and then times the
payoff ok
and so what we're going to be able to do
is derive a gradient ascent algorithm
actually so costly gradient ascent
algorithm as a function of theta to
maximize this thing to maximize the
expected value of this thing and that
and and this is a this is how we'll do
direct policy search ok so let me just
write out the algorithm and then we'll
go through why the algorithm that I
write down is maximizing this expected
payoff
so this algorithm is called the
reinforced algorithm the option
reinforced algorithm had a few other
bells and whistles but explain the code
the idea but they were enforcing that
the reinforced algorithm does the
following which is you're going to run
your MDP right and just you know run it
for a trajectory of tea time step so
again you know I'm just gonna well right
and and actually you would uh
technically you would run it for tea
time steps but you know let's just say
for now well we'll do only the thing in
blue we run it for one time set go to
sleep capital T equal one and then you
would compute the payoff right equals R
of 0 plus R of s 1 and then in the more
general case you know plus dot dot plus
R of s T and then you perform the
following update which is theta gets
updated as theta plus the learning rate
alpha times
and then times the payoff and again I'm
just setting capital t equals 1 if
capital t was bigger you would just sum
this all the way up to time T so that's
the algorithm that's on every iteration
through the reinforced algorithm and
through the reinforced algorithm you
will take your robot take your inverted
pendulum run it through t time steps
executing your current policy so choose
actions randomly according to the
current stochastic policy using current
values of the parameters data compute
the total sum rewards you receive let's
call the payoff and then update theta
using this funny formula right now on
every iteration of this algorithm you're
going to update theta and it turns out
that grandpa's is a stochastic gradient
ascent algorithm and you remember when
we talked about linear regression right
you saw me draw pictures like this if
there's a global minimum then gradient
descent would just you know take a
straight path to the minimum but
stochastic gradient descent would take a
more random path right towards the
minimum and it kind of also lays around
there maybe it doesn't quite converge
unless you slowly decrease the learning
rate alpha so that's what we have for
stochastic gradient descent for linear
regression what we'll see in a minute is
that reinforce is a stochastic gradient
ascent algorithm meaning that each of
these updates is random because it
depends on what was this state action
sequence that you just saw and what was
the payoff the you just saw but what
Willis show is that on expectation the
the average update you know this this
update to theta this thing you're having
two theta that on average let's see so
that on average this update here is
exactly in the direction of the gradient
so that on average
yeah because uh every every loo every
time through this loop you're making a
random update to theta and this random
and noisy because it depends on this
random state sequence right then just a
sequence is random because of the state
transition probabilities and also
because of the fact that you're choosing
actions randomly but on but the expected
value of this update you see in a little
bit turns out to be exactly the
direction of the gradient which is why
this report algorithm is a gradient
ascent algorithm so let's let's show
that now so
all right so what we want to do is
maximize the expected payoff which is a
formula we derive up there and so we're
going to want to take derivatives with
respect to theta of the expected payoff
right I'm just gonna copy that for me
there up there so that's a chance of
that see going through that say action
sequence time to pay off and so we want
to take derivatives of this and you know
so we can write go up hill using
gradient ascent so we're going to do
this in four steps now first want to
remind you when you take the derivative
of Smith of a product of three things
right so let's say that you have three
functions f of theta times G of theta
times H of theta so by the product rule
you know derivatives product grew from
calculus the derivative of the product
of three things is obtained by you know
taking the derivatives of each of them
one at a time right so this is f prime
times G times H plus G prime here so the
product rule from calculus is that if
you want to take derivatives of a
product of three things then you kind of
take the derivatives one at a time you
end up with three sums right and so
we're going to apply the product rule to
this where we have here
we have two different terms that depend
on theta and so when we take the
derivative of this thing respect to
theta we're gonna have of two terms that
correspond to taking derivative this one
is integral to doing that one's right
and so this derivative is equal to so
the first term is the sum over all the
state action sequences you have s0 and
then let's see so now we have PI of
theta excuse me the derivative respect
to pi theta as zero a zero
and then plus Oh and then times that pay
off right so the whole thing here is
then multiplied by the payoff okay so we
just applied the product rule for
calculus where for the first term in the
sum we kind of took the derivative of
this first thing and then for the second
term in the sum we took the derivative
of the second thing and now I'm gonna
make one more algebraic trick which is
I'm going to multiply and divide by that
same term and then most fine divided by
the same thing here right
so lots of multi but most times divided
by the same thing right and then finally
if you factor out so now the final step
is I'm going to factor out these terms
I'm underlining right because this terms
I underlined this is just you know the
probability or the whole state sequence
right and again for the orange thing
that this this orange thing right these
two orange things multiplied together is
equal to that for each thing in that box
as well
and so the final step is to factor out
the orange box which is just P of s 0 a
0 s 1 a 1 right so that's the thing I
boxed up in orange times then those two
terms involving the derivatives
okay and I think Oh
right where I guess this term goes there
and this term goes there and so this is
just equal to well and if you look at
the reinforced algorithm right that we
wrote down this is just equal to sum
over you know all the state action
sequences times the probability of the
gradient update
because uh I guess I'm running out of
colors but you know this is a gradient
update and that's just right equal to
this thing okay so what this shows is
that even though on each iteration the
direction of the gradient updates is
random the the expected value of how you
update the parameters is exactly equal
to the derivative of your objective of
your expected total payoff so we started
saying that this formula is your
expected total payoff so let's figure
out what's the derivative your expected
total payoff and we found that the
expected the derivative your expected
total payoff the derivative the thing
you want to maximize is equal to the
expected value of your gradient update
and so this proves that on average you
know if you have a very small learning
rate you end up averaging over many
steps right but on average the updates
that reinforce is taking on every
iteration is exactly in the direction of
the derivative of the expected total
payoff that you're trying to maximize
any questions about this yeah
oh is this impending the choice of the
dysfunction this is true for any form of
a stochastic policy where the definition
is that you know pi theta as zero a zero
has to be the chance of taking that
action in that state but this could be
any function you want it could be a soft
massacree logistic function and many
many different complicated features it
could be has been continuous the has
been differentiable function and
actually one of the reasons we shifted
to stochastic policies was because
previously just had two actions is
either left or right right and so you
can't define a derivative over a
discontinuous function like either left
or right but now we have a probability
that shifts slowly between what's the
probability to go let's go right and by
making this a continuous function of
theta you can then take derivatives in
five unison it doesn't really just a
function so another way to train a
helicopter controller is to use
supervised learning where you have a
human expert train you know so you can
also actually have a human pilot
demonstrate and just stay take this
action right and then you supervise the
running to just learn directly a mapping
from the state into the action I think
this I don't know this might be okay for
low-speed helicopter flight I don't
think it works super well I bet you
could do this in not crash a helicopter
but but to get the best results I
wouldn't use this approach it turns out
for some of the maneuvers where she
fight better than human pilots as well
oh and so for other types of policies
messy
[Applause]
so direct policy search also works if
you have continuous value actions and
you don't want to discretize the action
so maybe here's a simple example let's
say a is a real number such as the
magnitude that the force you apply to
accelerating left or right it's around
discretizing your inverted pendulum you
want to output a continuous number how
hard you're sorry to left or right or
for self-driving car maybe theta is the
steering angle which is a real value
number so a simple policy would be a
equals you know say the transpose s and
then plus Gaussian noise and if just for
the purpose of training you're willing
to pretend that your policy is to apply
the action theta transpose s and then a
little bit of Gaussian noise to it then
the whole framework for reinforce but
this type of gradient descent also will
also work and now I guess I reckon
implementing this you pray turn off the
Gaussian noise I know there are little
tricks like that as well um so let's see
some pros and cons of so when should you
use direct policy search and when should
you use value iteration or a value
function based type of approach so it
turns out this one setting actually
there are two settings where a direct
policy search works much better one is
if you have a palm DP P Oh in this case
that's a partially observable and that's
it for example you know for the inverted
pendulum that's a pro angle Phi you have
the car and this is your position X and
we've been saying that the state space
is X X dot Phi Phi dot right but let's
say that you have sensors on this
inverted pendulum that allow you to
Asia only the position and only the
angle of the inverted pendulum so you
might have an angle sensor you know down
here and you might have a position
sensor for your birthday pendulum but
maybe you don't know the velocity and
you don't know the angular velocity
right so this is an example of a
partially observable Markov decision
process because and what this means is
that on every step you do not get to see
the whole state because you you don't
have enough sensors to tell you exactly
what is the state of the entire system
so in a partially observable MDP at each
step you get a partial and potentially
noisy measurement of the state right and
then have to take actions I have to
choose an action a using these partial
and potentially noisy measurements right
which is uh maybe you only observe the
position and the angle but your senses
aren't even totally accurate so you get
a slightly noisy you know estimate or
the position you get a slightly noisy as
for the angle but you just have to
choose in action based on your noisy
estimates of just two of the four state
variables
it turns out that there's been a lot of
academic literature trying to generalize
value function based approaches the pom
DPS and they're very complicated
algorithms in the literature on trying
to apply value function based approaches
upon GPS but those algorithms despite
their very high level of complexity you
know are not are not widely in
production right but if you use the
direct policy search algorithm then
there's actually very little problem oh
let me just write this down so let's say
the observation is on every time step
you observe y equals x phi plus noise
right so you just don't know what is a
state and in a pom DP you cannot
approximate the value function or even
if you knew what was V Star right you
can't compute PI star because uh I mean
maybe you know what is pi star best
listen compute V Sarn pi saw but if you
don't know what the state is you can't
apply PI star to the state because it's
in so how do you choose in action if
you're using direct policy search then
here's one thing you could do which is
you can say that hi of given an
observation the chance of going to the
right given your parent observation is
equal to 1 over 1 plus e to the negative
theta transpose Y where I guess Y can be
you know one read X plus noise v plus
noise that's X plus noise and so you
could run reinforce using just the
observations you have to try to still
classically try to randomly choose an
action and nothing in the frame way we
talked about provenza's album from
working and so direct policy search just
works very naturally even if you have
only partial observations of the state
and more generally instead of plugging
the direct observations this can be any
set of
I just make a side comment for those who
didn't know what common causes are don't
have you don't but one common one common
way of using the right policy search
would be to use some estimate such as a
common filter a proper grammar model or
something to use your historical
estimates look don't don't just look at
your one set of measurements now but
look at all your historical measurements
and then their algorithms such as
something called a common filter that
lets you estimate whatever has the
current state the full state vector you
can plug that full state vector estimate
into the features you used to choose a
to choose an action that's a common
design paradigm if you don't know what a
common filter is don't worry about it
but you take take one a steal invoice
for something on them yeah but that's
one common paradigm where you could use
your partial observations that's been
the full state and plug that as a
features into the rent policy session
okay so that's one setting where the
right policy search works just just
applies in a way that value function
approximation is very difficult to even
get to apply now one last thing is one
last consideration for secure apply
policy search algorithm or a value
function transformation algorithm oh it
turns out the reinforced algorithm is is
actually very inefficient as in you end
up you know when I when you look at
research papers on the reinforced
algorithm it's not unusual for people
that run the reinforced algorithm for
like a million iterations or ten million
iterations so you just have to train it
turns out the gradient estimates for the
reinforced algorithm even though the
expected values right there's actually
very noisy and so if you train the
reinforced algorithm you end up just
running for a very very very long time
right it does work was a pretty
inefficient algorithm so that's one
disadvantage of the reinforced algorithm
is that the gradient estimates on
expectation are exactly what you want it
to be but there's a lot of variance in
the gradient so you have to run it for a
long time of a very small learning rate
but one other reason to use the right
policy search is
it's kind of ask yourself do you think
pi-star is simpler or is beast are
simpler right and so um here's what I
mean there are the in in in robotics
there's sometimes what we call low level
controls house and one way to think of
low level controls house is flying a
helicopter hovering the helicopter is an
example of a low-level control toss and
one way to inform me think of local
control houses kind of really skilled
human you know holding a joystick
control this thing making see the
depends decisions right so those are
kind of almost instinctual in the tiny
fraction of a second and almost by few
you could control the thing those those
are tend to be low level control Tasos
either the parents holding a joystick a
skill person because that inverted
pendulum or you know steer helicopter
those are low level control tasks in
contrast playing chess is not a
low-level control toss yeah because for
the most part to be a very good chess
player is not really a seat-of-the-pants
you know take a bit make a decision in
like in 0.1 seconds right you kind of
have to think multiple steps ahead and
in low-level control toss there's
usually some control policy that is
quite simple a very simple function
mappings of states the actions that's
pretty good and so that allows you to
specify a relatively simple class of
functions of PI star and direct policy
search would be relatively promising for
tasks like those whereas in contrast if
you want to play chess okay go or do
these things we have multiple steps of
reasoning I think that if you're driving
a car on a straight road that's a
low-level control toss we just look at
the road you just you know turn the
steering or a little bit to stay on the
road so that's a lot of control tasks
but if you are planning how to you know
overtake this car and avoid that other
car whether it's a pedestrian and the
bicycle is along the way then that's
less of a low-level controlled house and
that requires more multi-step reasoning
right I guess depend how aggressive a
driver you are right driving on the
highway you know may require more or
less multi-step reasoning where you want
to overtake this car before the trucker
comes in this Lane so that that type of
thing is more multi-step reasoning and
the person's like that tend to be
difficult for a very simple like a
linear function to be a good policy and
for those things in playing chess
playing go playing checkers a value
function approximation approach may be
more promising okay so any questions
about the oh and so again a long
helicopter flight actually my first
attempts for flying helicopters were
actually the right policy search because
flying helicopters I should see the
pants things but then when you try to
find more complex maneuvers then you end
up using something maybe closer to value
function approximation that method so if
you want to find very complicated
maneuver so the video you saw just now
the helicopter flying upside down the
algorithm implemented on for that pickle
video that was a different policy search
algorithm right no not exactly this one
a little bit different but that was a
tear apart see so geography but if one
helicopter fly very complicated maneuver
then you need something maybe closer to
the value from Shiprock Smith and Soda
and there is exciting research on how to
blend direct policy search approaches
together with value function
approximation book approaches so
actually alphago one of the reasons
alphago worked was sorry you know go
claim program rate by deep I was there
was a blend of ideas from both of these
types of literature which enabled it to
scale to a much bigger system to play go
in a very very very impressive
all right any questions about this
alright um so just final application
examples you know reinforcement learning
today is making strong let's see so
there's a lot of work on reinforce to
learning for game playing checkers chess
go
that is exciting um reinforcement
learning today is used in is using a
growing number of robotics applications
I think for controlling a lot of robots
there is a honor if you go to robotics
conferences if you look at some of the
projects being done by some of the very
large companies that make very large
machines right I have many friends in
multiple you know large companies making
large machines that are increasingly
using reinforcement if you control them
there is fascinating work using reports
of learning for optimizing
anti factory deployments there's
academic research we're still in
researcher as far as I know I shouldn't
mean maybe scientific deployed on using
reinforcement learning to build chat
BOTS and actually on using reinforcement
learning to build a a I based guidance
counselor for example right where the
actions you take up what you say to
students and then and then the reward is
you know do you manage to help a student
navigate their coursework or navigate
their career there is uh and there's
also starting to be applied to
healthcare where one of the keys are
reinforced with learning is is this a
sequential decision making process right
where do you have to take a sequence of
decisions that may affect your reward
over time and I think and in in
healthcare there is work on medical
planning where the goal is not you know
send you to get a blood test and then
we're done right
in complicated medical procedures we
might essentially get a blood test then
based on the outcome of the blood test
we might send you to get a biopsy or not
all right
ask you to take a drug and then come
back in two weeks but is this very
complicated sequential decision making
process for treatment of complicated
healthcare conditions and so this
fascinating work on trying to apply
reinforcement learning that instead of
multi-step reasoning where it's not
about what sense for treatment and then
you never see you again for the rest of
your life as well here's the first thing
you do then come back let's see what
stain you get to after taking this blood
test so let's see what you can see you
get to after trying a drug and then
coming back on the week to see what has
happened to symptoms but I think that
these are all sectors where
reinforcement learning is making inroads
or even actually stock trading okay
maybe not the most inspiring one but one
of my friends on the East Coast was and
then was a and just actually if you or
your parents invest in mutual funds this
may be being used to buy and sell shares
for them today depending on what back
they're investing I know what Bank is
doing this but I won't say it out loud
oh but but if you want to buy or sell
you know say a million shares of stock a
very large volume of stock you may not
want to do it in a very public way
because that will affect the price of
the shares right so if everyone knows
that a very large investors about to buy
a million shares or buy ten million
shares or whatever that will cause the
price to increase and this this is
disadvantage as a person wanting to buy
shares but so there's been very
interesting work on using reinforcement
learning to decide how the sequence out
you'll you'll buy how to buy the stock
in small Lots
in this trading market is called dark
pools these are Google if you're curious
as you don't bother to try to buy a very
large lot of shares or so a very large
lot of shares without affecting the
market price too much because the way
your effective market price always
breaks against you know is always
against you it's always bad right so
this work laid out as well
so anyway I think um many applications I
pursue you think that one of the most
exciting areas for reinforcement
learning will be robotics but well we'll
see what what happens over the next few
years
all right so let's see we're just five
more minutes um and and just a wrap-up I
think you know we've gone through quite
a lot of stuff I guess from supervised
learning to learning theory and advice
or apply learning algorithms to
unsupervised learning although it was it
k-means pca EMA share gaussian factor
analysis in Pentonville analysis to most
recently reinforcement learning with Val
function approaches fitted value
iteration policy search so feels like we
did feels like feels like I feels like
you've seen a lot of learning algorithms
um go ahead
how does enforce learn compared to have
a sarah learning I think of those as a
pretty distinct logicians yeah yeah so I
think and again actually I until I I
know a lot of non publicly known facts
about the machine there any world but uh
one of the things that I actually happen
to know is that some of the ideas our
adversary learning you know so can you
take a picture of ice you know very
little bit by tweaking a bunch of pixel
values they're not visible to human eye
they're fools our learning algorithm
into thinking that this picture is
actually cat one's clean all the cattle
whatever so I actually know that there
are attackers out in the world today
using techniques like that to attack you
know websites to try to fool you know
some of the websites down pretty sure
you guys use in fooled there anti-spam
anti-fraud anti undermining democracy
types of algorithms into
to make decisions so it's a it's
exciting time doing machine learning
right now that we get to fight battles
like these okay and and I think you know
I think we're really I think that what
the things you guys have learned in
machine learning I think all of you are
now very knowledgeable right I think all
of you are experts in all the ideas of
core machine learning and I hope that um
I think when we look around the world
there's so many worthwhile projects you
could do with machine learning and the
number of you that know these techniques
is so small that I hope that you take
these skills oh and some of you will go
you know build businesses and make a lot
of money that's great some of you will
take these ideas and help drive basic
research at Stanford or at other
institutions I think that's fantastic
but I think whatever you're doing the
number of worthwhile projects on the
planet is so large and the number of you
that actually know how to use these
techniques is so small that I hope that
you take these skills you're learning
from this cause and go and do something
meaningful and do something that helps
other people I've even seen this looking
valley that there are lot of ways you
know to build very valuable businesses
and some of you do that and that's great
but I hope that you do it in a way that
helps other people I think over the past
few years we've seen I think that uh in
Silicon Valley maybe ten years ago the
contract we had with Society was that
people would trust us with their data
and then we'll use their data to help
them but I think in the past year that
contract feels like that has been broken
and the world's faith in Silicon Valley
has been shaken up but I think that
places even more pressure on all of us
on all of you to make sure that the work
you go out into the world to do is work
that action is respectful of individuals
respectful individuals privacy is
transparent open and that ultimately is
helping drive forward humanity or
helping people helping drive forward
basic research or building products that
actually help people rather than exploit
their foibles for profit but to there
I hope that all of you will take your
superpowers that you now have an um go
out to do to do meaningful work and
let's see and I think oh end and lastly
just I just don't personally I want to
you know thank all of you on behalf of
the TAS the ho teaching team and myself
wants to thank all of you for your hard
work sometimes they go with homework
problems the good party also runs ago
Wow that she got that problem I thought
that was really hard or not project
Muslims go hey that's really cool look
forward to seeing your final project
results at the final poster session so I
know that all of you have worked really
hard and if you didn't don't tell me
that thing almost but I'm gonna make
sure you know there's a I think it
wasn't that long ago that I was a
student you know working late at night
on homework problems and and I know that
many of you have been doing that for the
homeworks standing for the midterm for
work on your final term projects so want
to make sure you know I'm very grateful
for the hard work you put into this
class and I hope that I hope that your
your heart and skills will also reward
you very well in the future and also
help you do work that that you find this
meaningful so thank you very much
[Applause]